Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Bitte gib jetzt das Passwort für diesen Podcast ein. Sag jetzt nicht Passwort.
Podcast.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer, was haben wir denn überhaupt? Fünf,
drei und sieben. Fünf, drei, sieben. 537.
Und wir haben den 15. November 2025.
Und ja. Wie wär's denn mal mit einem Einbruch? Irgendwo.
Mach ich den ganzen Tag.
Du machst das doch beruflich, oder?
Ja.
Und was muss man da so machen, um irgendwo reinzukommen? Ich hab gehört, das ist doch zwei Tage.
Ja, okay.
Cyber, Cyber-Tricks muss man machen.
Cyber-Tricks, genau. Ja, aber ich meine einfach mal so ein richtiger Einbruch
scheint ja so schwierig auch nicht zu sein. Haben wir ja gesehen in Paris.
Ja, das Problem ist, also was? Ein Einbruch ist nicht schwer.
Das ist, ein Einbruch ist nicht schwer. Da hast du recht.
Aber nicht erwischt werden ist halt schwer. Also das, hacken ist auch nicht
schwer. Nicht erwischt werden ist schwer.
Nur so.
Das macht doch mal Mut, weil viele Leute ja immer denken, Hacken wäre ja so schwierig.
Du kannst es auch, du kommst halt nur in den Knast.
Der Einbruch ist einfach, der Ausbruch wird schwierig.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Naja, auf jeden Fall war das eine sehr lustige Anekdote rund ums Louvre,
wo eine Baustellensituation genutzt wurde, um da quasi eine Backdoor zu schaffen
und dann haben sie mal die Diamanten rausgetragen, aber noch ein bisschen peinlicher
war natürlich die Nachuntersuchung, wo sie sich dann mal die ganzen Sicherheitssysteme angeschaut haben,
festgestellt haben, dass irgendwie die, was war das, das Überwachungskamera-System?
Kamera-Überwachungssystem des Louvre, ja. Also, Tim, ich weiß ja,
also guck mal, weil du jetzt von peinlich redest.
Ne?
Ich meine, das eine ist irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen von Diamanten
oder was das da war, von dem Napoleon oder wem auch immer, ist alles nicht mein Fachgebiet,
ob das peinlich war, dass die mit einer Hebebühne, die irgendjemand neben den
Louvre geparkt hatte für eine Baustelle,
da rein sind oder das Passwort, da weiß ich jetzt nicht genau,
ob ich jetzt wirklich sagen würde, das zweite war peinlicher.
Es war an sich eine Ansammlung von Peinlichkeiten auf allen beiden Seiten und so.
Die sind ja dann auch gefasst worden, weil die dann irgendwie auch ordentlich
Dinge zurückgelassen haben, mit denen sie dann schnell identifiziert werden konnten.
Vor allem haben die diesen Einbruch ja sogar noch, ich war erst überrascht,
weil es ja eigentlich würdest du denken, es ist ein Einbruch,
aber die haben das ja sogar während
des Betriebs gemacht, dadurch klassifizierte es dann eben als Raub.
Die hätten auch durch die Tür gehen können. Also nur da, also,
durch die Tür hätten sie reingekonnt, aber sie wollten halt natürlich durch
diese Hebebühne wieder raus.
Aha, das heißt, wenn man zu normalen Öffnungszeiten kommt, dann ist es Raub und kein Einbruch?
So habe ich das, also keine Ahnung, ich bin jetzt kein Räuber.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht wieder die berufliche, wie sich jetzt, sag ich mal,
Einbrecher und Räuber den Markt aufteilen.
Ich kenne das nicht genau, wie die Qualifikationen und ihre Geschäftsbereiche
sagen, nee, das ist hier Raub, das machen die Räuber.
Das machen die Räuber und hier nur die Einbrecher, aber vielleicht war das auch völliger Quatsch.
Auf jeden Fall sind die, also ich würde Juwelen dann klauen,
wenn möglichst wenig Leute da sind und nicht in einem Museum im Betrieb.
Wenn ich eh schon so eine schöne Hebebühnen-Installation da für mich beanspruchen kann.
Ja, vielleicht hat man ja auch keine Lust, über diese Laserstrahlen rüber zu
steigen, die dann überall quer verteilt sind.
Weißt du, wenn jemand zuschaut bei so einer Aufgabe, das macht einem ja auch
immer so ein bisschen Stress, wenn man beobachtet wird.
Da verliert man dann halt auch mal so ein Armband von irgendeiner Marie-Antoinette oder was.
Ich weiß es alles nicht. Louvre, meine Güte. Ich war übrigens an dem Tag da,
im Louvre, also am Louvre.
Und ja, ich musste mich noch im Freundeskreis rechtfertigen.
Freundeskreis, auch jetzt. Warum hast du nicht mehr was mitgemacht,
wenn die da die ganzen Juwelen haben fallen lassen, dass sie da mitnehmen können.
Ja, das wäre günstig. Ich glaube, das hätte am Flughafen nicht so gut geklappt dann mit denen.
Wobei jetzt irgendwie so ein Diadem von Marie Antoinette ist ja jetzt auch nicht so...
Das sieht doch nicht aus. Das ist ja heute völlig aus der Mode gefallen.
Ist die nicht auch der Guillotine dann zum Opfer gefallen?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wer Marie-Antoinette ist. Ich weiß,
von Napoleon weiß ich, dass er klein war und deswegen die halbe Welt erobern wollte oder so.
Ich bin da wirklich nicht belesen. Das ist nicht mein Fachgebiet.
Louvre als Passwort, da fühle ich mich zu Hause. Das ist mein Metier.
Okay, verstehe.
Aber das war doch irgendein Armband oder so.
Ja, ich habe das auch ehrlich gesagt auch nur so am Rande verfolgt und dachte
mir so, genau, was interessiert mich das schon.
Aber ich habe jetzt gelernt, wenn das zu Öffnungszeiten stattfindet,
das ist ein Raub und kein Einbruch.
Nein, das weiß ich nicht. Das ist völlig falsch. Also auch da, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Lass uns das nächste Thema machen. Wir haben jetzt schon wieder 500 Kommentare.
Was ich alles Falsches gemacht habe. Das stimmt allerdings, das stimmt allerdings. Na gut.
Ist es vielleicht auch, also Juwelenraub ist ja eigentlich auch so ein feststehender Begriff, ne?
Vielleicht ist es nie ein Juwelen, vielleicht ist es bei Juwelen immer Raub.
Weil das ja, also Juwelen kann man ja nur von Reichen stehlen und das ist ja
üblicherweise was Schlimmeres, wenn man Reichen was wegnimmt.
Hier, 16. Oktober 1793.
Nee, das war irgendwie Ende Oktober 2025.
Nee, aber am 16. Oktober 1793 ist Marie Antoinette auf dem Revolutionsplatz enthauptet worden.
Mit oder ohne, Armand?
Ja, weiß nicht, das dürfte dann dem Moment runtergefallen sein. Spätestens.
Nick, Kaiserin,
Eugenie. Eugenie wahrscheinlich? Wird das dann ausgesprochen? Marie,
Amélie und Hortense. Eine der gestohlenen Krollen wurde bei der Flucht der Diebe gefunden.
Kronen. Also alles nichts, wovon ich Ahnung habe. Diaphragmen,
Halsketten und Broschen.
Diaphragmen?
Diademe, sorry.
Ich will wirklich keine Ahnung.
Was... Jetzt mal ganz schnell zum Riesenthema.
Alright, also, was gibt's Neues? Chatkontrolle.
Ah, was Neues.
Ja. Nachdem, ja, Dänemark hat sich's anders überlegt, ne? Und jetzt?
Dänemark, also die sind da ja immer, es war ja ein Hin und Her und in Deutschland.
Aktueller Stand ist, Also nochmal, was ist die Situation mit der Chat-Kontrolle?
Was bezeichnet Chat-Kontrolle? Eine KI-Kontrolle der Kommunikation,
KI-basierte Kontrolle der Kommunikation auf deinem Endgerät vor einer potenziellen
Verschlüsselung mit automatisierter Meldung
an eine zentrale Strafverfolgungsüberwachungsstelle bei Verdachtsfall.
Kommission will das, Parlament will es nicht. Rat ist seit drei Jahren gespalten.
Dänemark ist im, weiß nicht, wievielte Ratspräsidentschaft sechste oder was
die versucht, das Problem zu lösen und hat jetzt gesagt, ja,
wir werden dann jetzt wir werden die Pflicht streichen,
Also eine Aufdeckungsanordnung, die Möglichkeit, dass der Staat anordnet,
dieses Hochrisikosystem wird jetzt angeordnet, dass sie das tun,
also verpflichten können sie es nicht.
Gleichzeitig wollen sie die Ausnahme, die es überhaupt erlauben würde,
die wollen sie dauerhaft implementieren.
Wir wissen, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, ist das die E-Privacy-Richtlinie von
2002, die das nämlich verbietet, wo es ja jetzt seit Längerem immer wieder diese
Ausnahme gibt, die sie immer wieder verlängern.
Diese Ausnahme, von dass es verboten ist, die wollen sie quasi zur Regel machen,
und dann möchten sie eine Überprüfungsklausel.
Einbringen, dass nämlich die Kommission beauftragt wird,
zu bewerten, ob es denn so reicht und ansonsten halt einen neuen Anlauf zu machen.
War auch so. Ja, die Überwachungsfetischisten werden gebeten,
zu prüfen, ob diese eingeschränkten,
Überwachungsmöglichkeiten ausreichen
und ansonsten, das haben wir mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ja ähnlich.
Das ist wirklich insgesamt so ein bisschen, es ist da so ein unwürdiges Geschacher.
Diese Idee ist einfach wirklich nicht gut und es wäre sinnvoll,
die jetzt mal zu beerdigen.
Aber man erkennt also dass auch hier Dänemark eben nicht anstrebt,
Das wirklich zu beerdigen. Gleichzeitig, mein Eindruck ist, die Kommission könnte
ja so oder so am laufenden Band neue Anläufe unternehmen.
Das heißt diese Überprüfungsklausel, das quasi zu automatisieren oder irgendwie
quasi eine Evaluation zu fordern, die dann eben vorhersehbar zu dem Ergebnis kommt,
mehr Überwachung wäre noch besser, weil es gibt ja immer noch Kriminalität das
ist natürlich schon irgendwie ein sehr einfach abgekartetes Spiel.
Schauen wir mal, wie das weitergeht, das wollen sie jetzt glaube ich nächste Woche dann vorlegen.
Immerhin zeigt sich, dass der politische Widerstand in Europa doch relativ groß
ist und dass das hier nicht einfach so durchgewunken werden kann und das wird
wahrscheinlich ein ähnliches Geeire werden, wie wir das schon bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung
jetzt über lange Zeit haben.
Also die Forderung wird wahrscheinlich immer wieder hochkommen,
aber ich glaube, dass der Gesamtwiderstand, sowohl der bürgerliche Widerstand
als auch der Widerstand aus dem Unternehmen, derzeit einfach noch zu stark ist,
als dass man da einfach drüber marschieren kann.
Aber auch nur in einzelnen Ländern.
Also hier ist es ja wirklich der deutschlandzentrierte Protest gewesen.
Natürlich aber auch, weil Deutschland jetzt eines der Länder war,
wo die Position… Ja klar.
Ich meine es ist ja nun mal, vielleicht nicht ausreichend, aber die Rolle von
Deutschland ist niemals irrelevant innerhalb von Europa,
von daher macht es schon Sinn und selbst so eine CDU geführte Regierung kann
da nicht einfach mal so eben freidrehen.
So, dann haben die GEMA und OpenAI sich vor Gericht getroffen.
Kannst du auch nur Gewinner geben.
Ja, wenn so zwei Kampfhunde aufeinander losgehen, dann weißt du irgendwie auch
nicht so richtig, für wen du jetzt die Daumen drücken sollst.
Ist tatsächlich schwierig. Also ich meine, die GEMA, traditionell keine Sympathieträgerin.
Und zwar nicht so sehr, weil man jetzt ihr Statut an sich,
ablehnen würde, sondern eigentlich eher so ein bisschen in ihrem Gebaren und
ihrer Radikalität und Kompromisslosigkeit, was einfach viele Diskussionen betrifft.
Ich würde sagen, dazu kommt natürlich noch,
dass sie also gegen die Idee, dass es so eine geistige Eigentumsvertretung für Künstlerinnen gibt,
die finde ich jetzt noch nicht mal so unglaublich schlecht.
Also die würde ich jetzt nicht vom Grund heraus ablehnen. Das Gebaren,
ja, natürlich, ich meine, das ist eine Interessenvertretung,
die Geld einsammelt, was erwartet man? Natürlich schreit die jedes Mal.
Aber was ja, glaube ich, bei NRG-Mal-Kritik nicht vergessen werden darf,
ist, dass auch ihre interne Struktur so eine von unten nach oben Verteilung hat.
Es gibt irgendwie nur wenige, die dort so diese Vollmitgliedschaften haben und
die Verteilungsschlüsse definieren können und große Künstlerinnen werden da
unproportional stärker übervorteilt als kleinere,
insbesondere,
weil wenn ich das richtig, also du kannst glaube ich jetzt,
also entweder du sagst, du machst eine Veranstaltung und sagst so,
welche Musik haben wir hier gespielt?
Da musst du ja alle durchgeben und dann wird danach ausgeschüttet oder was.
Oder du sagst, meine Güte, wir haben ja Musik bezahlt, wir bezahlen jetzt einen festen Beitrag.
Du bist eine Kneipe, da schickst du ja nicht jedes Lied, was du gespielt hast, da hoch.
Jetzt sagen wir aber mal, du bist eine Heavy-Metal-Kneipe.
Dann spielst du potenziell relativ viel Musik aus Europa und den USA,
für die überhaupt gar kein GEMA gilt.
Ein paar deutsche Kapellen spielst du so in dieser Zeit und zahlst einen monatlichen
Beitrag dafür, dass du in deiner Heavy Metal Kneipe Musik spielst.
Die GEMA nimmt diesen Geldbetrag und verteilt den aber nach dem sich bei ihr
ergebenden Schlüssel von dem, wo sie misst. mit anderen Worten,
den ganzen Tag spielt, wird, was ist, hört man heute irgendwie.
Jetzt wird es, Christiane, jetzt wird es wieder schwierig.
Durch die Nacht oder so, wie heißt, Helene Fischer oder, ähm,
Dieter Bohlen und Thomas Modern Talking, was man so hört heute.
Immer noch.
Ich glaube schon. Auch das weiß ich nicht.
Nein, das wissen wir nicht.
Aber ich weiß, diese Flat-Einnahmen, die werden quasi nach dem verteilt,
von wie es gemessen wird.
Und da, wo es gemessen wird, diese Heavy Metal Kneipe, so viel kann ich glaube
ich sicher sagen, wird mit ihrem Flat-Beitrag,
unproportional Dieter Bohlen und Helene Fischer oder wen auch immer zugutekommen
als der kleinen, aber übrigens sehr feinen deutschen Heavy-Metal-Szene.
An der Satzung gibt es viel Kritik. Ich habe mal hier von dem Thomas Stadler
einen relativ alten Text mit GEMA-Kritik.
Noch in die Shownotes getan.
Thomas Steiler, Rechtsanwalt, ne?
Genau, der Rechtsanwalt. Internet Law, genau.
Der erklärt da so ein bisschen, was die interne Struktur dieser GEMA angeht.
So, jetzt geht die GEMA hin und sagt, okay, pass auf, wir wissen,
dass ihr GEMA-Werke nehmt, um eure Open AI, um euer Chat-GPT oder eure KIs da zu trainieren.
Und sie haben auch ein Beispiel gefunden.
Passt auch. In der Weihnachtsbäckerei. in der Weihnachtsbäckerei.
OpenAI hat mit Rolf Zukowskis,
Lied, was jetzt schon, würde ich sagen, Mitte November allen zum Kotzen aus
dem Hals hängt. Und es ist erst November.
Man wird jetzt noch in vielen Kindergärten.
Lockt das die ganze Zeit bei dir so?
Nee, zum Glück nicht. Aber jetzt natürlich schon.
Weil die geben mal ausgerechnet.
Dieser Rohr, worum wurde ihn präsentiert von Lockbuch Ness Politik?
Zwischen Mehl und Milch.
Ich mache zum Beispiel nicht.
Oh nein, jetzt kriegen wir Ärger Mit der GEMA, ich höre sofort auf zu singen.
Und OpenAI hat aber argumentiert, ja, also pass auf, das wäre so.
Wir haben das nicht gemacht, denn ChatGPT hat diese Songtexte durch eine sequenziell-analytische,
iterativ-probabilistische Synthese selbst neu erstellt, nicht wahr?
Und damit hätte es eben nicht diese Texte einfach kopiert, sondern synthetisiert.
Durch eine probabilistische Synthese. Und deswegen schuldet man natürlich der Gema kein Geld,
weil da sind sie nicht so weit mitgekommen und haben dann eben in dem Auftaktprozess,
der hier stattgefunden hat, erst mal verloren.
Das wird natürlich nicht der erste gewesen sein, denn es wird weitere Verfahren geben.
Und was hier hinter sich verbirgt, ist, dass die GEMA.
Das Ziel verfolgt, ein Lizenzmodell zu erzwingen. Ähnlich wie Sie das ja über
viele Jahre Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete, vor nunmehr wahrscheinlich ungefähr 13, 14 Jahren.
Übrigens, herzlichen Glückwunsch, Tim. Wir hatten gerade wieder Geburtstag.
2011 hat Logbuch Netzpolitik angefangen, ich glaube am 5. November,
wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Nee.
Jetzt erwischt du mich irgendwie. Der Jahrestag, Logbuch Netzpolitik, 28.
Oktober, genau. 28. Oktober.
Ja.
Da war ja lange Zeit das Problem, dass die GEMA sich nicht mit YouTube darüber einig wurde,
was denn zu bezahlen ist an die GEMA, wenn ein YouTube-Video ausgespielt wird, in dem GEMA-Musik ist.
Dann gibt es da weitere Diskussionen, die sogenannte GEMA-Vermutung,
die auch der Sache zugrunde liegt, dass,
das Metal-Kneipen-Beispiel, was ich gerade genannt habe, potenziell sehr,
sehr wenig GEMA-Musikanten abspielt.
Aber die GEMA-Vermutung gilt, das ist auch super geil, so GEMA-Vermutung, das ist Macht.
Also da hast du gute Lobbyisten, wenn du quasi staatlich durchbekommst,
dass vermutet wird, dass alles erstmal deins ist.
Die hat die GEMA eben auch gegenüber YouTube geltend gemacht und so weiter und
wollten sie irgendwie Geld haben und YouTube hat gesagt, ja,
so viel Geld ist aber ein bisschen viel jetzt.
Und da gab es, der Zustand hat doch jahrelang angehalten, dass du auf YouTube
dann Videos nicht gucken konntest, weil gesagt wird, dieser Inhalt ist,
den können wir dir leider nicht zeigen, wegen der GEMA.
Was auch die GEMA jetzt nicht unbedingt viel beliebter gemacht hat.
War schon auch ein bisschen sagen wir mal gut gespielt von YouTube.
Irgendwann haben sie sich geeinigt, kann man nachhören, hört einfach die letzten
536 Folgen irgendwo drin, haben wir das behandelt und ich würde sagen,
wahrscheinlich irgendwo innerhalb der ersten 300 müsste das sein.
Und etwas ähnliches wollen sie natürlich jetzt für dieses KI-Training erzwingen
Und dazu gehören natürlich derartige Klagen und Forderungen und Gerichtsentscheidungen dazu,
um eben OpenAI in irgendeiner Weise an den Verhandlungstisch zu bekommen.
Dass sie also sagen, okay, wir demonstrieren euch mithilfe der existierenden Gesetze und Gerichte,
dass das, was ihr tut, so nicht in Ordnung ist und dass wir uns besser einigen,
sonst wird das irgendwie sehr ärgerlich für alle Beteiligten und wir gewinnen hier.
Aber das ist das Ziel, was die GEMA hier verfolgt und das ist ja ein Problem, dass...
Eigentlich viele Schaffende und Organisationen von Schaffenden haben,
seien es die Verlage, die Medienverlage, die Nachrichten erfassen,
generieren, verarbeiten, verifizieren und potenziell nur noch so ein KI-Futter dann produzieren.
Oder die GEMA, die echte, kreative, noch tatsächlich kreative Menschen vertritt,
die ihre Musik selber machen, statt mit einer KI und damit Trainingsmaterial
für eine KI generieren, um sich potenziell abzuschaffen.
Weil ich weiß nicht, ob du schon den schönen Weihnachtssong in der Weihnachtskonditorei kennst.
Von Ralf Zukovskaja, der mit Hilfe von Chat-GPT entstanden ist.
Gleichzeitig werden ja die Spotifys und so heute schon mit KI-generierter Musik
geflutet. Also da sind ja tatsächlich...
Relevante Interessen und auch vertretbare Interessen und Lebensunterhalte dran,
die hier eine Rolle spielen.
Trotzdem, wenn GEMA und OpenAI sich vor Gericht sehen, kann es nur Gewinner geben.
Ich frage mich jetzt allerdings auch selbst und das glaube ich bestimmt nicht
alleine, welche Legitimität hat denn jetzt eigentlich die Forderung beider Seiten?
Du hast auf der einen Seite so die Position mit, naja, wir kopieren ja nicht
eins zu eins, sondern salopp formuliert, wir entziehen den Dingen ja nur ihr Wesen.
Ja, also das ist ja letztlich das, was eigentlich die AI, LLL-Algorithmen machen
und Copyright deckt halt,
wie der Name sagt, also gut, Urheberrecht ist nochmal was anderes,
aber ist ja auch eine Copyright-Diskussion.
Also ist das sozusagen ein Kopieren des eigentlichen Inhalts oder im Sinne des
Urheberrechts, wird hier quasi das Recht des Urhebers, was ihnen eingeräumt wird, verletzt.
Und ich finde, das ist...
Nicht nur rechtlich, sondern vielleicht auch so, ich sag mal,
netzmoralisch ein bisschen schwer zu entscheiden, diese Frage.
Also ich hab da nicht so eine richtige, klare Position, weil auf der einen Seite
sehen wir ja immer, dass diese ganzen Urheberrechtseinschränkungen einfach auch
die Kreativität immer eingeschränkt haben,
Verwendung von Musik im Podcast und so weiter.
Auf der anderen Seite hast du auch einen absehbaren technischen Verlauf.
Also ich meine, diese Technologien, die gehen nicht mehr weg.
Das ist ganz im Gegenteil. Sie werden natürlich auch noch sehr viel besser werden,
was dann vielleicht eher noch dieses Problem, was man jetzt schon sieht, noch größer machen.
Sodass man dann irgendwann sagen kann, es gibt fast überhaupt gar nichts Schützenswertes
mehr, weil allem sofort sein Wesen entzogen werden kann, indem man es halt analysiert.
Die Software ist ja heute schon nicht nur in der Lage, dem Text seinen Inhalt
und seine Aussage herauszuziehen,
zusammenfassen, neu formulieren etc. Das haben wir ja alles schon gesehen.
Und genauso ist es bei Bildern, bei Video und nun eben auch bei Musik.
Ja, und das ist halt wirklich die Frage, ist das...
Ist das schlecht?
Was? Das KI?
Ja, das, was da passiert. Also ist das für uns insgesamt schlecht?
Wird das dazu führen, dass originäre Urheber generell es noch schwerer haben
werden, überhaupt das Ur zu heben?
Und wozu wird das führen?
Ich glaube, man muss ja so einen kurzen Schritt nochmal zurückgehen.
Warum gibt es überhaupt Urheberrecht? Also wofür ist das da?
Und das ist, damit Menschen, die ein Werk kreiert haben,
daraus in irgendeiner Form sichergestellt wird,
dass sie daraus nach bestimmten Regeln erstens darüber entscheiden können,
wie das genutzt wird und unter Anwendung der Gesetze daraus für sich irgendwie
eine Monetarisierung erzielen können.
Gäbe es kein Urheberrecht, dann könnten beispielsweise Musikerinnen nicht erzwingen,
dass sie von Aufzeichnungen ihrer Musik,
dass sie davon Geld bekommen, könnten nicht erzwingen, dass das niemand anders.
Macht und würden eventuell andere Leute damit Geld verdienen mit ihrem Werk.
Wie es ja auch oft passiert.
Das ist mal so die grundsätzliche Idee. Wenn jetzt jemand ein Buch schreibt,
dann räumt die Person einem Verlag die Verwertungsrechte ein,
der Verlag verkauft das Buch, druckt das und so weiter und es kann jetzt nicht
jeder andere Verlag sagen, wir haben auch einen Drucker, wir drucken das jetzt auch mal.
Also das ist ja schon irgendwie halbwegs, da gibt es ja erstmal grundsätzlich
ganz gute Ideen, warum es das gibt und diese Ideen haben sicherlich auch relativ
viel Kreativität ermöglicht, dann gibt es irgendwelche Extreme bei bestimmten
Musikern und so, da kann man irgendwie alles kritisieren.
Und die Argumentation ist, wenn jetzt ein Musiker oder eine Musikerin hingeht
und schreibt ein neues Lied,
dann hat die das ja, die hat ja auch überhaupt erstmal Musik machen von anderen
gelernt und die hat auch Radio gehört, die hat viele andere Musik gehört und
dieser kreative Prozess des Schaffens eines neuen Liedes oder eines neuen Stückes
durch diese Musikantin,
Komponistin oder sonst was, ist das Ergebnis aller Inspirationen,
die sie in ihrem Leben hatte.
Insbesondere wahrscheinlich auch musikalische Inspiration durch andere Künstler.
Trotzdem schafft sie ein genuin neues Werk.
Und dann sagen wir, ist klar, dafür kannst du jetzt Urheberrecht beanspruchen.
Wenn das Werk zu nah an etwas anderem ist, wenn du irgendwie einen bekannten
Song spielst, musst du Abgaben zahlen oder so an die GEMA. Auch irgendwie ganz gut.
Und ich denke aber, wo dieses System als solches an seine Grenzen kommt,
ist, wo jetzt quasi OpenAI etwas baut, was am laufenden Band auf Basis aller Musik,
auch neue Musik machen kann.
Also ChatGPT ist ja sehr viel produktiver in,
oder jetzt ChatGPT also irgendeine Musik-AI ist ja sehr viel produktiver als
jede andere Komponistin oder Band oder so überhaupt.
Kannst du die ganze Zeit, ich weiß nicht, wie diese Dinge heißen,
ob es da irgendeine Schätzung gibt, wie viele Lieder die am Tag generieren.
So viel du da bereit bist, Computing-Power reinzustecken.
Soviel du da bereit bist, Atomkraftwerke nebenzubauen. Ja, und dann haben ja
wahrscheinlich auch alle Musik dieser Welt gehört.
Ja, und ich glaube, dass dieser,
Zustand, dass das jetzt industriell verwertet werden kann und kreiert werden
kann und so weiter, das Urheberrecht in seiner bisherigen Form eben vor eine
Situation stellt, die es so,
nicht die einfach wahrscheinlich kompletten neue Realitäten kreiert,
mit denen wir auch noch nicht ganz umzugehen wissen.
Genau, weil wir selber Schwierigkeiten haben, das zu bewerten und ich meine,
ist ja auch nicht so, dass wir ähnliche Dinge nicht schon vorher gehabt hatten in der Musik.
Also diese ganze Diskussion um Sampling und das Wiederverwenden von bestimmten Elementen.
Also bekanntest Beispiel der Amen Break, so ein ganz kurzer Taktausschnitt aus so einer B-Seite.
Eines Liedes, was quasi die Basis von ganzen Musikgenres geworden ist.
Kannst du das kurz erklären?
Der Amen Break. Der Amen Break ist der meist gesampelte Musikteil der Welt.
Das ist so dieser eine von den Winstons auf der B-Seite einer Single rausgebracht.
Das Lied enthielt halt so einen kurzen Instrumental-Break, wo einfach nur Schlagzeug
und der ist millionenfach kopiert und eingesetzt worden und im Prinzip so die
ganze Basis des Hip-Hop und Breakbeat und so weiter,
das hat das alles irgendwie definiert.
Das ist einfach der berühmteste.
Kannst du den einmal einspielen?
Ja, das kann ich sicherlich machen.
Kurz gucken.
Warte mal, da muss ich mal kurz hier...
Oder darf man das nicht?
Ja, aber nee, warte mal. Ich müsste den mal kurz raussuchen.
Den habe ich jetzt hier nicht so ready.
Und ich muss hier auch noch einen zweiten Track hinzufügen kurz. Das geht aber.
Habe ich jetzt nicht drauf vorbereitet.
So, ja, hier habe ich den.
Und das ist nur so ein ganz kurzer Ausriss aus diesem Lied.
Danach geht es irgendwie weiter und die anderen Instrumente setzen wieder ein.
Aber dieser Breakbeat an dieser Stelle, der ist dann einfach irgendwann aufgegriffen
worden von Tausenden von Künstlern und ist einfach der berühmteste Break.
Und ja, der und das ist ja nicht das einzige Sample, was aufgegriffen wurde
und es gab ja immer diese Diskussion mit, ist, wenn ich jetzt hier ein Stück
aus einem anderen Musikstück rausnehme, wirklich nur eine Sekunde irgendein Schrei irgendwie,
das weiß ich hier, Snap, you've got the power und so weiter,
das sind alles so Lieder, die sind einfach zusammengesetzt aus ganz vielen anderen.
Quellen und dann war ja immer diese Argumentation, ja ist das jetzt geklaut
oder ist sozusagen diese Kreativität, das aufzunehmen und überhaupt erstmal
zu was Eigenem zu machen,
steht das dann komplett wieder für sich und man kann jetzt nicht irgendwie bis
in alle Ewigkeit, bis zur ersten Note, die jemals gespielt wurden,
zurückgehen und alle irgendwie vergüten.
Also das ist natürlich etwas, was jetzt durch die AI-Systeme nochmal von ganz
anderen Dimensionen stattfindet, weil es sich halt jetzt, wie ich schon formuliert
habe, das Wesen erkannt wird.
Man erkennt Stimmung, man erkennt Beats, Rhythmen, Melodien, Klangmuster,
Songstrukturen, das ist ja total Meta und ist in der Lage eben mit diesen automatisierten
Systemen das alles nachzubauen und dem immer wieder so einen neuen Flair zu geben.
Du bleibst im Genre, aber du schaffst im Prinzip was Neues und ist das jetzt
irgendwie gut, schlecht, geht die Welt davon unter, ist schwer zu beantworten.
Geht sie unter? Ich glaube, worum gerade gekämpft wird, ist,
wer verdient demnächst wie noch Geld mit sowas?
Ja, aber die Argumentation gab es ja auch da schon. Wenn mir die Samples geklaut werden.
Das ist richtig. Nur, dass halt, also ein Sample wird dir gestohlen,
ist halt ein Unterschied zu allen Musikern, wird alle Musik verwurstet und etwas
geschaffen, was mehr Musik am Tag macht, als alle Musiker in ihrem ganzen Leben.
Also diese, die Dimension ist halt eine andere.
Weißt du, was ich meine? Also ich glaube, diese armen Brother-Leute,
die werden jetzt nicht, die werden sich eventuell geärgert haben,
zu viel oder zu viele nicht genug, wahrscheinlich meistens ärgern sich die Leute,
dass sie nicht genug Geld bekommen haben, ja, aber die werden jetzt nicht,
die sind nicht zugrunde gegangen daran und,
out of business gegangen, weil dieses Ding da gesampled wurde.
Nochmal, ich kenne den Fall überhaupt nicht, ne, aber im Moment steht ja quasi
zur Disposition, ob es überhaupt noch eine Grundlage dafür geben wird,
dass Menschen Musik machen.
Und dass es jetzt eine neue Form der Verwertung gibt, naja, also ich glaube,
das wird jetzt halt ausgehandelt werden. Ich würde gerne noch kurz sagen,
wie die GEMA sich das vorstellt.
Die haben ein Lizenzmodell sich überlegt. Das ist natürlich auch wieder großzügiges Lizenzmodell.
Es hat zwei Säulen und zwar die erste Säule ist die Beteiligung der UrheberInnen
an allen wirtschaftlichen Vorteilen der Anbieter und zwar in Höhe von 30 Prozent der Einnahmen.
Und danach kommt eine Mindestvergütung, die anknüpft an die Menge des Outputs.
Und die zweite Säule sind die Folgenutzungen. Das heißt, die UrheberInnen sollen
an allen wirtschaftlichen Vorteilen, die sich durch die Folgenutzung von KI-generierten
Musikinhalten entstehen können.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, wäre es so,
sagen wir mal, es geht jemand hin und
sagt, ich mache ein KI-supportendes Software-Tool für Bedroom-Producer.
Und dafür, das verkaufe ich,
das kostet 100 Euro im Monat, dann sollen schon mal 30 Euro jeden Monat einfach
grundsätzlich schon mal an die GEMA gehen und dann die Folgenutzung,
also irgendein Werk, was damit geschaffen wurde, also jede Musik,
die mit dieser Software irgendwann einmal geschaffen wurde, da gibt es natürlich
noch Folgenutzungsvergütung.
Das erscheint mir jetzt auch ein bisschen üppig.
Natürlich steigt die GEMA in so eine Diskussion nicht mit einer Minimalforderung
ein, aber ich glaube, das hat sie hier auch nicht getan.
Ich glaube, ich werde das Thema nicht lösen. Ich bin auch kein Musiker.
Und ich bin auch keine KI, wollte ich sagen.
Falls das mit dem Armin Break für euch auch neu war, ich verlinke mal ein Video, was das erklärt.
Da gibt es mittlerweile sehr viele Videos, die die Geschichte vom Armin Break
erzählen, aber das ist meines Wissens.
Welches war das erste? Weil die anderen müssen dem jetzt Geld geben.
Ja, also ich verlinke das, was sehr früh im Internet schon aufgetaucht ist,
das ist jetzt 19 Jahre alt und ich finde, das ist immer noch the most moody
und das könnt ihr euch mal anhören,
schauen, das ist wirklich sehr gut.
Ja, die Grundsatz, vielleicht noch ein letztes Wort, diese Frage,
die sich hier für Musik und GEMA stellt, die stellt sich ja auch für Menschen,
die, was weiß ich, ihren Code auf GitHub geladen haben und damit Anthropic oder
wen auch immer trainiert haben.
Die stellt sich für die ganzen Reddit-Nutzerinnen, die ihre Meinung in dieses
Forum geschrieben haben und dafür leider nie entlohnt wurden,
für diese wunderschönen Beiträge, die sie da geleistet haben.
Das ist schon ein großes Thema und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sich das klärt.
Meine Vermutung wäre, gar nicht, bis es zu spät ist.
Was passiert dann, wenn es zu spät ist?
Weiß ich nicht, aber dann sind auf jeden Fall Realitäten geschaffen,
die sich nicht mehr ändern lassen.
Ähnlich wie so bei Datenschutz. Facebook gab es schon, als dann irgendwann mal brauchbare,
Datenschutzvorschriften erlassen wurden, die es vielleicht ermöglicht hätten,
Facebook zu verhindern, aber dann war es halt zu spät und dann ist es jetzt eben so. Ähm,
Das war eine ganz gute Überleitung, also wie ich finde, sehr gute Überleitung,
ganz gut hingekriegt zum Omnibus,
dieses Thema, was der Thomas ja auch schon in der letzten Sendung ein bisschen
angesprochen hat, da sind jetzt weitere Details rausgekommen.
Also eine… Kurz erklären, was mit dem Omnibus gemeint ist, bitte.
Genau, eine Gesetzesänderungsinitiative, die so mehrere Gesetze auf einmal ändern soll auf EU-Ebene,
insbesondere im Bereich der Datenschutz- und Verbraucherrechte.
Es soll im Prinzip so der Data Act überarbeitet werden, damit auch die Open
Data Richtlinie, die Verordnung über den freien Fluss nicht personenbezogener Daten,
der Data Governance Act, dann wird der DSGVO betroffen,
wie sensible Daten, also einmal so alles ein bisschen querbeet.
Man könnte auch sagen, so ein bisschen holistischerer Ansatz an die Gesetzgebung.
Mal so ein bisschen out of the box über alles drüber rasieren,
statt immer nur so im Fachbereich bleiben.
Ja, so eine Realitätsanpassung, wo man überall so ein bisschen die Schärfe rausgenommen
wird, damit das alles besser zusammenspielt.
Einmal mit dem Bus drüber. Einmal alles unter den Omnibus.
Genau, wir sollen jetzt unter den Omnibus geworfen werden So.
Was steht da jetzt spezifisch drin?
DSGVO, in dem Bereich wollen sie ein bisschen was ändern. Ich hatte ja gerade
schon angesprochen, Datenschutz-Grundverordnung, die, ja, ich würde sagen,
so ein, zwei Jahrzehnte zu spät,
den Betroffenen von Daten so ein paar Rechte gegeben hat,
die es vielleicht wirksam verhindert hätten, dass enorm große zentralisierte
Datenverwertungs- und Tracking-Geschäftsmodelle in dieser Form hätten entstehen können.
Die gab es aber dann schon und damit hat es letztendlich unterm Strich zu ein
paar nervigen Cookie-Bannern und ein paar Abmahnungen geführt,
wenn man jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr böse auf die DSGVO blicken würde.
Ich habe das jetzt mal pointiert. Und was wollen sie machen?
Sie sagen, ja, wenn du Daten sammelst, also du sammelst personenbezogene Daten ein von Leuten,
dann gibt es ja bestimmte Sachen, die du damit immer machen darfst,
bestimmte Sachen, die du nur bei einem berechtigten Interesse machen darfst,
das du benennen musst und bestimmte Sachen, die du gar nicht darfst.
Ja, und dann eine ganze Menge Sachen, die du nur mit Einwilligung dann darfst.
Und hier sagen sie jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn du mit den Daten,
die du hast, eine KI trainieren möchtest, brauchst du keine explizite Einwilligung,
sondern das ist eine grundsätzlich von deinem berechtigten Interesse gedeckte Handlung.
Es ist gerade so, dass, ich glaube LinkedIn war das jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen
Thema in letzter Zeit, dass LinkedIn gesagt hat, ja pass auf,
wir werden jetzt hier mit euren Posts und mit euren Messages und so werden wir
jetzt eine KI trainieren und damit fangen wir an.
In einem Monat und bis dahin könnt ihr versuchen, in den Einstellungen den Knopf
zu finden, wo man Opt-out macht.
Und dann haben sich die Leute auf LinkedIn die Empfehlung gegeben,
wo man versuchen könnte, diesen Knopf zu finden.
Großes Geschrei. Und dann ist der Drops gelutscht.
Hier würde also quasi entschieden werden, dass LinkedIn mit dieser Herangehensweise,
dass das so in Ordnung ist.
Dass sie also sagen, ein Opt-out ist ausreichend.
Bei vielen anderen Sachen würde man eben sagen, opt-in. Also es muss quasi spezifisch
das Einverständnis erklärt werden,
nicht das Einverständnis eingeräumt werden, dass das Einverständnis entzogen werden kann.
Gibt es da nicht so eine schöne Formulierung, the tyranny of the default?
Also das, was der Default ist, wird halt für 90, 95 Prozent der Leute einfach
gelten und damit ist es natürlich schon eine,
sagen wir mal eine entscheidende eine entscheidende Erleichterung von KI-Trainings,
wenn du sagst, ja ja, das darfst du einfach grundsätzlich, da musst du dich
jetzt nicht rumärgern, dass dir irgendjemand das noch zustimmt.
Reicht, wenn du irgendwo einen Knopf versteckst, wo sie Opt-out machen können.
Das ist schon eine starke Erleichterung davon.
Sie definieren auch pseudonyme Daten ein bisschen enger, sodass das quasi weniger
darunter fällt und Sie wollen,
das mit dem Online-Tracking angehen.
Da sagen Sie auch, da reicht dann nämlich jetzt auch ein Opt-out statt einer Einwilligung.
Und da hätten Sie sehr gerne dann einen Weg für automatische,
maschinenlesbare Angaben individueller Präferenzen, wenn es denn dafür mal einen Standard gibt.
Und das finde ich ganz lustig, weil es gab doch diesen HTTP-Header,
Do Not Track, den hat dann einfach keiner respektiert.
Und dann hat man gesagt, naja, okay, dann müssen wir eben akzeptieren,
dass sich dieser Standard nicht wirklich durchgesetzt hat. Aber technisch gab es einen.
Ja, und der war aber immer freiwillig und deswegen hat sich natürlich auch kein Mensch dran gehalten.
Und wenn das halt nicht Pflicht ist, sich daran zu halten, dann macht es natürlich auch keiner.
Richtig. Deswegen wurde der Standard dann mehr oder weniger wieder abgeschafft.
Und jetzt sagt die EU, also wenn ihr jetzt mal einen hättet,
dann könnten wir uns vorstellen, dass wir dafür den Weg ebnen,
dass man den auch respektieren muss.
Also es ist schon ein bisschen,
realitätsfremd?
Weiß ich gar nicht. Also ich meine, ehrlich gesagt, fände ich das ja mal ganz
gut. Ich meine, diese Cookie-Banner-Geschichte, das ist ja nicht zu ertragen.
Richtig. Richtig. Es ist nicht zu ertragen, es ist todnervig.
Was ich hier realitätsfremd finde ist, in der Regel, wenn ich jetzt eine Seite
besuche, nehmen wir, welche Seite nehmen wir? Spiegel Online.
Ja, gehe ich auf Spiegel Online.
Dann muss ich dem Tracking zustimmen. Das Tracking nimmt ja aber nicht der Spiegel
Verlag Rudolf Augstein KG, vor,
sondern eine Reihe unterschiedlichster Werbevermarkter,
die Inhalte über diese Seite mit ausspielen, die quasi eingebettet werden und
dadurch mich tracken beim Spiegel,
beim gleichzeitigen, darauffolgenden Besuch von heise.de, süddeutsche.de und wo sie alle sind.
Das heißt, dieses Einwilligungsverhältnis, ich möchte hier getrackt werden,
ist ja eigentlich gar keins, das ich mit Spiegel Online habe,
sondern mit den 193 oder was auch immer, es sind ja wirklich teilweise so viele,
wenn du dann mal in diese Cookie-Dinger gehst, wo du da zustimmst,
da sind ja wirklich teilweise bis zu wirklich mehrere hundert unterschiedliche
Organisationen, die du dann da die Rechte einräumst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das bei Spiegel so ist, aber auf bestimmten Seiten gibt es
ja echt spannende Möglichkeiten, mit wie vielen Organisationen,
die ich gar nicht kenne, ich hier eine vertraglich-rechtlich-bindende,
ja, ihr könnt mich tracken.
Vereinbarung treffe, wenn ich das klicke.
Und beim Besuch der nächsten Seite treffe ich ja eigentlich wieder mit den Gleichen
diese Vereinbarung, was denke ich relativ wichtig ist,
weil es ist nicht wirklich der Spiegel oder die Webseite, die ich besuche,
die mich da trackt, sondern eben Eingebettete, die diese finanzieren.
Und eigentlich müsste es reichen, wenn ich einen Brief schreibe an alle diese
Unternehmen, die das tun und sagen, übrigens wenn ich im Internet bin,
ich möchte von euch nicht getrackt werden, ich möchte nicht,
dass ihr Profile über mich bildet und damit ist das geklärt und dann bräuchte
ich auch nie wieder einen Cookie-Banner.
Aber dieser Teil scheint, also diese technische Realität, die sich dahinter
verbirgt, scheint nicht allen ganz klar zu sein.
Was aber der EU-Kommission offenbar klar ist, ist, dass Medien,
Verlagshäuser, deswegen habe ich sie gerade auch als Beispiel genannt.
Darin ihre wirtschaftliche Grundlage haben. So finanzieren die sich.
Alle diese Verlage, alle diese Seiten finanzieren sich zu großen Teilen durch Werbeeinnahmen.
Und diese Werbeeinnahmen sind deshalb da, weil da Werbevermarkter Werbung platzieren.
Und die platzieren die auf sehr vielen Webseiten.
Und aus den Webseiten, die wir besuchen und den Inhalten, die wir lesen,
machen sie Profile, anhand derer sie uns die Werbung anzeigen,
die unser Adblocker dann versucht wegzumachen. Ja, das ist dann,
so funktioniert dieses Modell.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, ausgerechnet Verlage sind davon ausgenommen,
dass ich zustimmen muss, ob ich von irgendeiner anderen Firma getrackt werde,
das kann ja nicht sein, weil diese Erlaubnis zum Tracking oder getrackt werde
ich doch gar nicht von dem Verlag. Ich werde ja von jemand anders getrackt.
Und wenn ich jetzt sage, ich darf dem, ich habe ein Opt-out oder Pipapo,
irgendeine Möglichkeit zu widersprechen, dann kann es ja nicht sein,
dass jetzt die Medienseiten davon ausgenommen werden.
Weißt du? Also, verstehe ich. Weißt du?
Ich meine, wenn es...
Wenn es wirklich nur die Werbung wäre, also wenn es wirklich nur darum ginge,
mir Werbung anzuzeigen, die für mich auch wirklich relevant ist,
würde ich sagen, ja hurra.
Ja, weil was mich ja noch mehr nervt, ist ja irrelevante Werbung.
Ich will jetzt hier nicht die ganze Zeit Zeug angezeigt werden,
was mich nicht interessiert.
Mal abgesehen davon, dass ich generell von Werbung auch überhaupt nicht verführt
werden will. Aber das wäre ja, sagen wir mal, in gewisser Hinsicht noch irgendwie akzeptabel.
Das Problem ist halt nur, dass diese Unternehmen diese Profile aufbauen,
teilweise dann, und so sehr sie eben in der Lage sind, das auch auf die konkrete
Person zurückführen und speziell dann halt in geschlossenen Systemen wie Facebook
damit natürlich mehr als nur ein Werbeprofil machen,
sondern eben auch ein politisches,
potenziell politisches Profil aufbauen.
Und das hat man ja nun schon sehr oft, Brexit, Trump-Wahl etc.
Diese ganzen Ausspielungen, die dann eben genutzt werden, um mich auch gezielt
zu beeinflussen und an der Stelle wird es eben wirklich problematisch.
Und was würde jetzt passieren?
Also angenommen, man würde jetzt Tracking verboten, ich kann in meinem Browser sagen,
ja, mich trackt ihr einfach mal gar nicht, ich will hier auch gar keinen Cookie-Banner,
sehen, mein Browser sagt einfach mich nicht und damit habt ihr das alles komplett zu unterlassen.
Da habe ich natürlich erstmal keine Möglichkeit festzustellen,
ob es nicht doch getan wird.
Naja, aber ich hätte ein Recht.
Genau, man hätte zumindest ein Recht und das ist halt potenziell Schwierig für
die Unternehmen dann irgendwann ihre Zahlen zu rechtfertigen.
Da werden sie natürlich alle laut schreien und sagen, ja der Untergang ist nah,
weil wenn wir das jetzt hier nicht mehr machen können, dann gibt es ja unsere
ganze Branche nicht mehr und wir werden alle sterben.
Andererseits, wenn es ohnehin für alle gilt, dann müssen halt auch alle damit
klarkommen und dann geht es glaube ich am Ende auch allen besser.
Aber dieser Cookie-Banner-Wahnsinn, ich meine,
auf jeder einzelnen Webseite immer wieder jeden Tag aufs Neue irgendwie in irgendein
Verhalten gescampt zu werden darf, so dermaßen und das kann einfach nicht die Antwort sein.
Nee, natürlich nicht. Also die Antwort wäre, einmalig zu sagen,
pass auf, ich will einfach, also lass, ich möchte auch, ich möchte das nicht.
So, das müsste reichen. Und das würden dann einmal alle machen und dann wäre
das Internet am nächsten Tag zu.
Und dann würde ChatGPT fragen, ob irgendwas passiert ist. Und ChatGPT würde
sagen, tut mir leid, habe ich nicht lizenziert.
Am besten geht da einfach zur Arbeit und richtet euch über nichts auf.
Das wäre ja auch eine Möglichkeit, mit der Sache uns zu gehen. Aber diese.
Regelung mit den Cookie-Bannern ist, denke ich, realitätsfremd insofern,
als dass sie nicht die Realität abbildet, wer mich da trackt und wer nicht.
Und genauso ist die Idee, dass ich da jetzt einzustimmen kann oder nicht,
genauso realitätsfremd.
Und erst recht ist realitätsfremd zu sagen, Medien werden ausgenommen von diesem
Ding, damit die wirtschaftliche Grundlage nicht entzogen wird,
weil das ja wiederum bedeutet,
genau da, wo du potenziell politisch relevante Inhalte konsumierst,
genau da darf Tracking einfach stattfinden.
Aber es ist ja nun mal kein Verhältnis, was ich mit dem Medium habe.
Es ist ein Verhältnis, was ich mit den Inhalten habe, die die Seite einbettet.
Also das überzeugt mich nicht.
Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass sie da genau wissen, wie der Hase läuft.
Außerdem sagen sie, ja, pass auf.
Wir schwächen den Schutz sensibler Daten.
Und zwar dürfen die ja grundsätzlich kein, also in der DSGVO sind besonders
sensible Daten ethnische Herkunft, politische Meinungen religiöse,
weltanschauliche Überzeugungen,
Gewerkschaftszugehörigkeit genetische Daten, biometrische Daten,
Gesundheitsdaten Daten zum
Sexualleben sexuelle Orientierung das sind besonders sensible Daten und,
Es gibt ja dieses wunderschöne Beispiel, das ist viele Jahre alt,
aber ich behandle das gerne in Vorträgen.
Wir haben es auch hier im Logbuch mal behandelt, wo Amazon eine KI trainiert
hat, um die Vorauswahl von Bewerberinnen zu treffen. Kannst du dich daran erinnern?
Ich fasse es kurz zusammen. Amazon kriegt ja sehr, sehr viele Bewerbungen.
Dann werden die irgendwie gescreent und dann kommen Bewerberinnen in Betracht,
und dann werden die zu einem Bewerbungsgespräch eingeladen.
Und je nachdem, wie das Bewerbungsgespräch verläuft, werden sie am Ende angestellt oder nicht.
Und diesen Prozess, den bildet Amazon natürlich digital ab und dann kannst du
darauf eine KI trainieren.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, Okay, liebe KI, bitte sorge dafür,
dass wir nicht so viel Zeit in Bewerbungsgesprächen verbringen,
die am Ende nicht in einer Einstellung münden, sondern wir trainieren dich jetzt
bitte darauf, dass du uns nur die
Leute schickst, die am Ende des Bewerbungsgesprächs auch den Job kriegen.
So, haben sie gemacht, dann haben sie gesagt, okay, natürlich darf das Ding
jetzt nicht explizit mit, kriegt halt keine Geschlechtsdaten oder so.
Es stand nicht dran, männliche Bewerberin, weibliche Bewerberin oder so,
Namen wurden halt entfernt, also so grob wurde geguckt, dass da jetzt nicht
direkt gesagt wurde, Männlein, Weiblein,
ethnische Herkunft oder Immigrationshintergrund, also sowas wurde halt nicht
strukturiert mit erfasst.
Und dann haben sie am Ende rausgefunden, dass ihnen das Ding jetzt nur weiße Männer schickt.
So, sehr interessant. Warum war das so?
Nun ja, A, offensichtlich überstehen weiße Männer die Vorstellungsgespräche
bei Amazon mit größerer Wahrscheinlichkeit als Frauen und Menschen mit anderen
Hintergründen als weiße Männer.
Dann hat Amazon gesagt, okay, scheiße, jetzt haben wir hier also eine sexistische,
rassistische KI, die die Bewerberauswahl trifft, das können wir so nicht machen.
Also lassen wir die Auswahl in Zukunft wieder von echten Rassisten und Sexisten
treffen, weil das können wir machen.
Also die KI haben sie...
Ist wirklich so, ja, wahre Geschichte. Der Witz ist aber, die haben dem Ding
ja nicht gesagt, das ist ein weißer Mann und das nicht.
Sondern die KI hat quasi aus dieser Menge der Daten offensichtlich an,
was weiß ich, Lebensläufen, Schulen, die Menschen besucht haben,
Universitäten, was auch immer, irgendetwas hat da mit Geschlecht und ethnischem
Hintergrund korreliert.
Ich meine, wenn du, was weiß ich, an einem IIT in Mumbai studiert hast,
lässt sich auch, es ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du vielleicht in Indien
geboren bist, lässt sich da nicht verleugnen.
Natürlich gehen da auch Menschen aus aller Welt hin, weil es ein Elite-Institut ist.
Aber wie auch immer, es gibt halt Faktoren, die da stehen, die sehr stark mit
ethnischer Herkunft, religiöser, weltanschaulichen Hintergrund,
und Ethnie und so weiter korrelieren.
Da sagen die jetzt, okay, diese Einschränkung, die gilt jetzt nur noch explizit
für diese Merkmale, nicht für Daten, aus denen sich das erschließen lässt.
Also genau dieses Amazon-Beispiel, es wurde nicht explizit erfasst,
sensible Daten darfst du nicht explizit erfassen, aber wenn sie deduziert werden,
also wenn sie sich aus den Kontexten ergeben, Ja, mei, was willst du machen?
Nur bei Biometrie sagen sie, das muss weiterhin besonders geschützt werden.
Und dann sagen sie, ja, die KI-Verordnung, die wir hier haben,
die möchten wir auch ein bisschen gezielt vereinfachen, damit es eine zeitnah
reibungslose und verhältnismäßige Umsetzung gibt bei der KI-Verordnung.
Unter anderem sagen sie, dafür möchten sie so ein AI-Office direkt unter der Kommission haben.
Dort bündelt sich dann die Aufsicht.
Wir erinnern uns, dass ja die Ursula von der Leyen in letzter Zeit relativ oft
mit US-Vertreterinnen, sowohl der Wirtschaft als auch der Regierung, über so, naja,
was macht denn die EU da zur Behinderung unserer Geschäftsinteressen? redet.
Und dann sagt sie, ja, okay, dann bündeln wir mal die Aufsicht,
lieber direkt im Office, was direkt unter mir ist. Das ist das AI-Office dann eben.
Und das ist dann für die Regulierung der VLOPS, was sind das?
Very large Online-Platforms.
Also ab 45 Millionen monthly unique EU-Users, oder ich glaube noch nicht mal
unique, 45 Millionen EU-User,
bist du dann ein VLOPS und dann sitzt du sitzt im Ursels-AI-Office,
ist dann deine Kontrolle.
Wahrscheinlich sitzt du in Irland direkt neben der Datenschutzbehörde da.
Und apropos Datenschutz, da wollen sie es also auch erleichtern.
Sie wollen den KI-Unternehmen, die jetzt ein berechtigtes Interesse haben,
deine personenbezogenen Daten zu verarbeiten, den wollen sie es erleichtern,
den Datenschutz einzuhalten.
Indem man den Datenschutz einfach ein bisschen...
Wie macht man das wohl? Indem man den halt natürlich einfach abschafft.
Ja, zumindest reduziert, ja.
Wir möchten euch rechtliche Vorgaben machen, die leichter einzuhalten sind.
Das hören andere nicht so häufig.
Könnte man jetzt zum Beispiel bei Räubern und Einbrechern auch sagen,
wir möchten euch erleichtern, die gesetzlichen Vorgaben einzuhalten.
Deswegen ohne euer berechtigten Interessen jetzt hier auch ein bisschen mehr zu würdigen.
Und ich weiß gar nicht so, ich muss ehrlich sagen, diese...
Diese Diskussion, wie viel kann jetzt diese KI an Wohltat über die Menschheit bringen,
wie viel Produktivität, Wirtschaftswachstum, Potenzial, weiß auch immer, ist da drin.
Wie sehr müssen wir uns da vielleicht dagegen schützen, dass diese ganze KI-Datenzentralisierung,
wir lernen daraus, alles in
den USA ist und es in Europa gar nichts mehr gibt. Also alle diese Themen.
Ich finde das sehr spannend, wie da gerade diese.
Naja, wie eben alte Ideen darüber, wie etwas funktioniert, wieder an ihre Grenzen stoßen.
Das Konzept Datenschutz ist ja mit Facebook auch an seine Grenzen gestoßen.
Da gab es irgendwie mal die Idee, ja, meine Güte, jemand hat eine Adresse und
so weiter. Er hat 5, 6 Daten, Geburtsdatum hat er auch noch 7.
Und das müssen wir jetzt schützen. Und dann kommt auf einmal irgendwie so ein
Google und so ein Facebook und so nehmen alles an Daten auf und wir sagen,
ja, wir hätten hier so eine Idee, wir könnten so eine Datenschutzgrundverordnung
und so und dann stehst du ja irgendwann mit streckenweise,
inzwischen durch die Realität,
realitätsfremd gewordenen Konzepten, die irgendwann mal sinnvoll gewesen wären,
um eine bessere Realität zu, in Richtung einer besseren Realität zu lenken.
Und das gleiche ist jetzt irgendwie so bei diesen KI-Sachen.
Ich bin mir, ich weiß es nicht.
Was findest du Tim? Sollte eine KI dein Leben, also am besten,
möchtest du lieber von einer chinesischen oder von einer US-amerikanischen KI
terrorisiert werden für den Rest deines Lebens?
Ach, Hauptsache...
Oder möchtest du einen Opt-out-Button haben?
Also ich meine, ob mich jetzt diese KIs dann terrorisieren, ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Frage.
Dass man eine Balance schaffen muss für Training, sehe ich schon,
ob die Novelle, die jetzt hier angestrebt ist,
diesen Anspruch erfüllt und ob sie zu viel von den bestehenden Schutzmaßnahmen,
wegnimmt, muss man glaube ich dann im Detail sich mal anschauen. Wann kommt das raus? 19.
November soll das vorgestellt werden, was jetzt konkret ist?
Ja, aber Netzpolitik hat ja quasi schon in den Entwurf reingeschaut sozusagen.
Ja, okay.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da eine gute Antwort drauf habe, um ehrlich zu sagen.
Na gut, dann setzen wir uns mit Palantir auseinander.
Wir haben ja hier darüber gesprochen, dass in Baden-Württemberg ein neues Polizeigesetz
diskutiert wurde und dass in diesem Polizeigesetz eben auch die Grundlage für
eine Palantir-Nutzung geschaffen wird. Palantir, das,
Massendatenanalyse-System für Polizeibehörden aus dem Hause Peter Thiel.
Und der Vertrag dafür besteht übrigens schon seit dem Frühjahr. Finde ich auch lustig.
Da haben die quasi schon den Vertrag unterschrieben für die Software,
die sie gesagt, müssen wir noch, wir machen schon mal den Vertrag,
wir ändern dann noch eben die Gesetze, dass das passt.
Und dann haben die Grünen, und die CDU, die ja in Baden-Württemberg regieren,
mussten sich einigen und ich glaube, das hat Thomas ja auch schon,
Ich glaube, es war Thomas in der letzten Sendung gesagt. Die Grünen haben jetzt zugestimmt.
Aber muss man auch sagen, sie sind ein harter Hund. Harter Hund, die Grünen.
Dafür bekommen sie jetzt anderthalb Tausend Hektar mehr Schwarzwald-Nationalpark.
Also das ist natürlich auch, naja, also ich meine, ist ja auch etwas.
Mehrere Kreisverbände der Grünen waren dagegen. Es gab Demos dagegen,
wir haben hier darauf hingewiesen. Es gab die Petition dagegen,
13.000 Leute in kürzester Zeit.
In der ganzen Diskussion und Kampagne war aber dann eben auch inhaltlich in
der Diskussion mehr Parlamentierthema als diese Massenfahndung grundsätzlich,
also die Zusammenführung der Daten.
Außerdem in dem Polizeigesetz drin eine Experimentalklausel,
die die Verarbeitung von Daten erlaubt,
bei der Entwicklung, dem Training, dem Testen, der Validierung und der Beobachtung
von IT-Produkten einschließlich KI-Systemen und KI-Modellen außerhalb von rein
wissenschaftlichen Forschungsarbeiten.
Also sie sagen quasi, die Daten, die es da gibt, die dürfen zur Produktprüfung,
die dürfen einfach verwendet werden.
Und die Begründung leuchtet natürlich auch ein, ja, wenn man solche Systeme
bauen will, muss man die eben auch mit Realitätsdaten testen,
prüfen und so weiter und deswegen dürfen wir das jetzt auch.
Das macht schon technisch Sinn, aber ist natürlich auch sehr schwierig.
Sehr hemmsärmlich, jetzt da wirklich so eine komplette Carte Blanche,
inklusive KI, Modelle, Produkt, nicht wissenschaftlich und so,
das ist schon ein sehr starker Schritt nach, in eine Richtung der YOLO-Datenverarbeitung.
Es ist wirklich interessant, wie groß die Sucht der Polizeibehörden nach diesem
Palantir-System ist, als ob es nichts anderes geben könnte auf diesem Planeten.
Offensichtlich sind da Funktionalitäten drin, die alle wirklich komplett heiß machen.
Naja, also ich glaube, dass das schon auch aus der Tätigkeit und den Herausforderungen
dieser Tätigkeit nicht überraschend ist.
Wenn du erstens
mal durch die Föderalismusprinzipien eh potenziell 16-fache Datenhaltungen hast
und außerdem alle möglichen Datenbanken getrennt sind und du auf jede einzelne
Datenbank ein einzelnes Auskunftsersuche,
wie wir jetzt da gucken, darf ich da überhaupt rein?
Und dann sagt jemand, pass auf, wir haben eine Idee.
Alles hier rein, Suchbegriff, zack, bumm.
Und das ist ja auch die Kritik an dieser ganzen Sache, dass es auf unterschiedliche
Daten nur zu unterschiedlichen Zwecken, mit unterschiedlichen Begründungen usw.
Zugegriffen werden darf. Und da haben wir uns alle was bei gedacht bei den Gesetzen.
Und diese Idee wird jetzt durch dieses System ad absurdum geführt.
Und gleichzeitig sind das natürlich
diese gesetzlichen und Datenhaltungsrealitäten sicherlich ein sehr.
Sagen wir mal, starkes Hemmnis beziehungsweise Quelle der Frustration bei der Polizeiarbeit.
Dafür wurden sie ja auch gemacht, dafür haben wir ja die Gesetze,
damit die eben nicht mit irgendeiner Massenüberwachung genau sowas haben.
Aber mir leuchtet schon ein, dass wenn du jetzt irgendwie einen Polizisten fragst
und sagst, pass auf, hättest du gerne hier so eine, so ein Chat-GPT für,
für alle Daten, die du gerne haben möchtest, dann würden die natürlich sagen,
ja, das würde mir durchaus meine Arbeit erleichtern.
Und dann sagt man, ja klar, wenn die Arbeit erleichtert wird,
dann können wir mehr Verbrechen verfolgen, dann kommen mehr in den Knast,
das ist ja viel besser dann.
Und dann sagen die, klar, wir wollen auch eine moderne KI haben.
Also ich kann, mich wundert nicht, dass sie darauf abfahren.
Aber es ist eben, deren Rat ist nicht, deren Einschätzung ist nicht unbedingt
die, nach der man sich richten sollte,
wenn man eine Demokratie aufrechterhalten möchte.
Ja, aber das wurde jetzt, ist durch. Die Grünen stehen dafür in der Kritik.
Und ja, denke, Markus Reuter hatte das, glaube ich, auch bei Netzpolitik.org kommentiert.
In der Diskussion ging es halt viel mehr um Parland hier, als um welche Folgen
diese massenautomatisierte Zusammenführung von Daten grundsätzlich hat.
Und das sollte man in Zukunft noch mal mehr in den Vordergrund stellen,
weil auf Bundesebene wird der gute Dobrindt das ja jetzt auch alles wollen.
Der will auch alle Daten auf einen Haufen.
Und dann gibt es noch ein, es ist eher so ein kleines Ding, jedes Jahr gibt
es dann den BSI-Lagebericht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die das Ding überhaupt noch inhaltlich über,
wahrscheinlich ändern sie ein paar Zahlen und schreiben ein anderes Jahr drauf,
weil es ändert sich ja nichts an der Lage.
Es ist immer dramatisch, immer schlimm, niemand lernt draus.
Und dann haben sie jetzt gesagt, ja, jetzt machen wir das NIST-2-Umsetzungsgesetz.
Jahr NIS verorten, die ist ungefähr vor drei Jahren von der EU definiert worden.
Jetzt musste man die mal langsam umsetzen. Die EU hatte schon gesagt,
wenn ihr das nicht macht, dann gibt es hier Strafe.
Jetzt haben sie da irgendein Umsetzungsgesetz verabschiedet und ich muss sagen,
ich habe es mir noch nicht mal angeguckt.
Weil wenn du dir anschaust, welcher Schaden,
und ich glaube da irgendwie in einem BSI-Lagebericht, 82% der Unternehmen haben
irgendeine Form von Schäden, ja, durch den Cyber.
Wenn du dir so eine Situation anschaust, da finde ich es ja schon wirklich.
Absurd, dass man in einer solchen Situation jetzt noch auf den Staat schaut
und sagt, so schaffe er ein Gesetz, das endlich die Unternehmen schützt und
sie verpflichtet, was weiß ich,
Schwachstellen zu fixen, um ihre eigenen genuinen, direkten finanziellen Interessen zu schützen.
Endlich muss der Staat etwas tun. Der eine Bereich, wo der Staat eigentlich
nichts tun muss, weil wenn die Unternehmen bereit sind, diesen Schaden für sich
in Kauf zu nehmen und nichts dagegen tun wollen,
wieso sollte der Staat denn da jetzt eingreifen?
An der Stelle, wo Dritten ein Schaden entstehen kann, was weiß ich,
wenn es um kritische Infrastrukturen geht, wenn es um Datenschutz geht oder
so, da könnte man natürlich sagen, okay, hier bist du außerhalb deiner unternehmerischen
Freiheit, so viel Schaden in Kauf zu nehmen, wie du möchtest.
Hier nehmen nämlich andere Schaden, da haben wir Gesetze. Aber genau da passiert ja dann nichts.
Wenn irgendwie wieder irgendeine Bude aufgemacht wurde und so und so viel Daten
rausgetragen wurden, das ist ja straffrei.
Da passiert ja nie etwas, wenn jetzt irgendwie,
was weiß ich hier, diese Carriot-Geschichte, die wir letztes Jahr da beim Kongress
auch behandelt hatten oder so, es ist ja nie so, dass da irgendwie ein großartig
angemessener Schaden für das Unternehmen entstünde.
Das wäre ja etwas, am Schaden anzusetzen für Dritte.
Stattdessen schreibt man das fünfte Gesetz, was jedem Unternehmen vorschreibt,
seine IT-Sicherheitslücken zu reduzieren. Warum?
Das können die doch machen, wie sie wollen. Also verstehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich erkenne da wirklich keinen Regelungsbedarf.
Man muss sie einfach zu ihrem Glück zwingen.
Ja, aber warum?
Naja, weil sie doof sind. Ja und?
Also seit wann schützen wir denn jetzt die Doven?
Also das ist doch nicht... Nein, ich meine, nein, wirklich. Ernsthaft.
Also seit wann ist das... Also an der Stelle, ja? Ja.
Wir schützen die Doofen, indem wir sagen, keine Ahnung,
du darfst Kindern kein Alkohol verkaufen. Ja, weil die sind zu doof dafür.
Oder die werden dann noch döver oder so. Oder die dürfen keine Zigaretten verkaufen,
weil die können noch nicht einschätzen, dass sie davon süchtig werden,
ihre Lunge ruinieren und sterben.
Da kann man ja, aber da schützt man sie ja wirklich.
Man gibt ja nicht den Kindern Vorschriften und sagt, wenn du rauchst,
lieber Achtjähriger, dann gibt es aber eine Strafe, da gibt es jetzt ein Gesetz,
dass du das nicht darfst.
Man schützt ja indirekt, indem man die Unternehmen verpflichtet,
ihre Sicherheitsstandards anzuheben, schützt man ja potenziell deren Kunden
oder Infrastrukturen, die davon dann letzten Endes betroffen sind,
wenn die Unternehmen out of business gehen.
Aber genau das meine ich ja, also erstens gehen die wenigsten Unternehmen wegen
sowas out of business, aber das ist ein anderes Thema, diejenigen,
die den Schaden tragen, die willst du schützen.
Jetzt werden seit sechs, sieben Jahren am laufenden Band von irgendwelchen Hack-and-Leak-Operations
werden personenbezogene Daten geleakt. Am laufenden Band.
Strafen dafür? Keine.
Nichts. Gar nichts. Also Motel One, der ist ja sogar noch so frech gewesen,
hat dem Staat die Schuld gegeben, dass er seine Datenhaltung da nicht im Griff
hatte. Also völlig absurd.
Und diejenigen, die ja wirklich dann betroffen sind und den Schaden haben,
die kriegen weder Kompensation, es gibt diejenigen, die den Schaden verantworten,
kriegen keine Strafen, obwohl sie erkennbare rechtliche Pflichtverletzungen
begangen haben im Schutz dieser Daten.
All das. Also es ist ja nie irgendwas passiert.
Und jetzt sagt man, jetzt verpflichten wir euch sicher zu sein.
Also ich verstehe es nicht. Der einzige Aspekt, den ich daran verstehen könnte, wäre,
gut, dadurch, dass es eine gesetzliche Baseline gibt, wird Unsicherheit etwas
weniger zum Wettbewerbsvorteil.
Das könnte ich hier verstehen. Aber die grundsätzliche Idee,
im Jahre 2025 irgendwie zum Start zu schauen und zu sagen,
so tue er etwas gegen diese ganzen fahrlässig mit ihren Daten und ihren IT-Systemen
umgehenden Unternehmen,
um sie vor sich selber zu schützen.
Also du meinst, es wäre sinnvoller, einfach Strafen für solche Leaks zu erhöhen,
um sozusagen die Konsequenzen teurer zu machen, um die Unternehmen darüber zu
zwingen, zu reagieren, weil am Ende geht es halt nur über das Geld.
Und die Schäden, ganz kurz, wenn ich das noch anbringen darf,
die Schäden, die die Wirtschaft hat, also die Unternehmen haben durch Cybera,
das sind ja hauptsächlich direkte Geschäftsschäden durch Ransomware,
damit Produktionsausfall,
entsprechende Betriebsunterbrechungen und Wiederaufbau und so weiter.
Also es sind ja messbare Schäden, die sind ja da und die passieren seit vielen
Jahren in gleicher Form. Niemand lernt draus.
Ich bin jemand, der versucht, diese Lehren in die Welt zu tragen,
der versucht, an diesem Zustand etwas zu ändern.
Und ich muss auch sagen, dass dieser Zustand mich betrübt. Gleichzeitig verdiene
ich damit mein Geld, also sichert mir erstmal noch ein Einkommen.
Aber mir ist wirklich nicht klar,
und man würde ja vielleicht auch von mir erwarten, dass ich sage,
wenn ich dann in so ein Unternehmen reinkomme und sage, meine Güte,
wie sieht das hier aus, Kraut und Rüben oder so.
Aber das Letzte, was mir da einfällt, ist, dass ich da sitze,
mir das angucken und denke so, hier müsste aber jetzt mal der Staat eine klare
Kante zeigen. Also der Gedanke kommt mir irgendwie nicht.
Und dir ist klar, Tim, dass wir dann auch das Passwort ändern müssen.
Oh Gott, wirklich. Das kann ich mir dann wieder nicht merken.
Nehmen wir einfach Louvre. Da kommen die nie drauf.
Ach ja. Ich habe schon vor langer, langer Zeit diesen schönen Begriff der rentablen
Sicherheit kennengelernt.
Besonders bei Banken, das war so im Kontext von so Kreditkartenbetrug und so
weiter immer wieder viel.
Der steckt halt tief drin Sicherheit wird nur dann angestrebt oder technisch
auch forciert wenn es teurer ist unsicher zu sein als sicher,
und darüber dieser Hebel ist wahrscheinlich am Ende der einzige der greift,
ähm.
Ja, du hast aber natürlich das Präventionsparadox in dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Ich bin ja IT-Sicherheitsberater, das heißt, ich habe mit sehr vielen unterschiedlichen
Unternehmen zu tun, in denen Menschen verantwortlich sind für IT-Sicherheit.
Wenn die ihren Job gut machen geht jemand hin und sagt da müssen wir irgendwie
sparen das ist alles völlig klar aber ich denke auch, dass inzwischen die Lehren
eigentlich andere sind weil was du was die Lehre aus dieser,
Ransomware-Pandemie ist,
dass du resiliente Infrastrukturen bauen musst dass du wieder priorisierte Wiederanlaufkonzepte
brauchst und so das kann auch niemand anderes für dich machen Das muss jedes
Unternehmen selber machen.
Und die, die es nicht tun, denen fliegt das halt irgendwann um die Ohren und
dann stehen sie halt wochenlang still.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Staat da jetzt hingehen muss und sagt so,
pass auf, es wäre schon ganz gut, wenn ihr den Kern eures Geschäftsbetriebs
gegen eine seit fast einem Jahrzehnt prävalente und bekannte Bedrohung vornehmt.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das, also weißt du, ich verstehe es nicht vom ...
Vom Ansatz her, und ich glaube auch nicht, dass es am Ende den Missstand beseitigt.
Weil der Missstand auch nicht beseitigt wird, ist, dass wir weiterhin Internet durch Kupfer kriegen.
Eine faszinierende Meldung. Die Deutsche Telekom hat inzwischen 11,8 Millionen
Haushalte, Firmen und Behörden mit Glasfaser versorgt.
Und beklagt, dass nur 16,1% davon auch mit einem entsprechenden Vertrag darauf zugreifen.
Das bedeutet, 84% des Glases, das die Deutsche Telekom verlegt hat, ist dunkel. Dark Fiber.
Und ich habe mich sehr gewundert, weil ich das,
also es ist deswegen halt schrecklich, weil wir diese Infrastruktur ja brauchen
und wenn den Anbietern signalisiert wird, dass es keine Nachfrage an dieser Infrastruktur gibt,
dann haben sie keinen Anreiz, diese Infrastruktur zu bauen.
Und dann werden wir hier demnächst eben mit unseren Dieselmotoren und unseren
Kupferkabeln irgendwie in so eine Steampunk,
Fork der Realität gehen, während woanders Zukunft stattfindet.
Und wir beklagen ja schon sehr lange, dass dieser Glasfaserausbau eigentlich
überfällig ist und jetzt straft die Realität im Prinzip das Geschäftsmodell ab.
Also habe ich mal gefragt, was stimmt mit den Leuten nicht?
Und da habe ich sehr, sehr viele Antworten auf Mastodon bekommen,
primär wurde, ich habe zusammengefasst also einer sagte zum Beispiel der monatliche
Preis ist sehr viel höher als bei einem VDSL oder DOCSIS, also Cableanschluss.
Der Innenausbau kostet mehrere tausend Euro ich weiß nicht, welchen Innenausbau
die Person jetzt meinte, ist ja auch sehr unterschiedlich ob es im Haus oder
Also vermutlich ist damit gemeint,
es wird ein Glas ans Haus gelegt und dann muss das noch im Mehrfamilienhaus
verteilt werden oder so.
Es würde die hohe Geschwindigkeit nicht gebraucht. Und weil man keine Telearbeit
oder Homeoffice macht, reicht eben,
oder nee, weil es eben so ein CG-Nut, also nicht mit einer festen eigenen IP
ist, könnte man eben auch nicht dann von zu Hause die Arbeiten erledigen, die man bräuchte.
Also die Leute, ich habe das mal tatsächlich von ChatGPT zusammenfassen lassen,
erster Grund, kein erkennbarer persönlicher Bedarf, zweiter Grund, hohe Kosten,
Ausbau- und Verfügbarkeitsprobleme und viele sagen dann, sie warten jetzt noch
so ein bisschen oder sie sind mit den Vertragskonditionen nicht zufrieden.
Das war so ein bisschen diese Erfassung anekdotischer Evidenz,
warum Menschen Glasfaseranschlüsse, die an ihrem Haus liegen, nicht nutzen.
Ja, alles auch absolut nachvollziehbare Gründe, insbesondere natürlich der des
monatlichen Preises, wenn jetzt so ein Glasfaseranschluss, so hier dieselben
Daten, nur teurer, das ist natürlich nicht besonders attraktiv.
Da muss man sich jetzt wenig drüber wundern. Das Problem mit dem Innenausbau
ist natürlich ein echtes Problem.
Also wenn man jetzt wirklich, es gibt ja diese verschiedenen Kategorien,
Fiber to the Home, Fiber to the Curb, Fiber to the, weiß ich nicht, Flat oder so.
Also hast du es quasi nur an der Straße, musst du selber dafür sorgen,
das dann ins Haus zu bekommen.
Hast du es im Haus, zum Beispiel in so einem Mehrparteienhaus,
richtig was bringen tut es natürlich erst, wenn du dann auch eine entsprechende Verteilung hast.
Dazu müssen dann Kabel im Haus gelegt werden. Das ist natürlich aufwendig bei
großen Häusern und dann eben potenziell teuer.
Dann kommt halt die Telekom und sagt, naja, also wenn ihr das haben wollt,
dann müsst ihr das irgendwie auch mitfinanzieren, weil sonst rechnet sich das nicht.
Kann ja alles verstehen. Vor allem ist ja erstmal beim Glasfaserausbau muss
man auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen unterscheiden mit Glasfaser verfügbar auf den weiten Strecken.
Also ich meine, die großen Datenknoten sind natürlich ohnehin mit Glasfaser verbunden.
Ja klar, das sind aber auch keine Haushalte.
Genau, aber sagen wir mal, dass Orte überhaupt mit hohen Datenraten versorgt werden können,
insbesondere um dann die Kunden anzubinden, die auch wirklich einen hohen Datenbedarf haben.
Also im Privatbereich kann ich das durchaus verstehen, dass manche mit einem
DSL-Anschluss, also zumindest mit einer Größenordnung von 200 Megabit oder sowas,
zufrieden sind, weil das eben tatsächlich
für den eigenen Surfbedarf und Streamingbedarf ausreichend ist.
Aber hab mal ein Unternehmen mit 10, 20 Mitarbeitern, dann sieht das schon ganz anders aus.
Nicht nur, weil du unter Umständen an ganz andere Netzlogistiken angebunden
sein musst, sondern weil du halt einfach viele Leute sozusagen auch gleichzeitig
versorgen musst über einen Anschluss.
Ähnliches gilt für Hotels oder so, die halt ihren Gästen irgendwie schnelles
Netz bereitstellen müssen.
Und das ist halt einfach der Bedarf. Das sind dann vielleicht nicht viele Kunden,
aber es sind eben wichtige Kunden und es sind vor allem wichtige Verfügbarkeiten,
die einfach erforderlich sind,
damit nicht Unternehmen ihre Standorte aufgeben müssen.
Ich fände es halt ich frage mich wirklich also ja, ich habe einen Glasfaseranschluss
und ich habe auch den großen da gab es zwei, ich habe den teureren genommen
ich habe immer gesagt, gib mir den teuersten, besten, den will ich haben ähm,
Ich verstehe durchaus, dass ich jetzt wahrscheinlich keine nennenswerte Degradierung
meines Services oder meines Surferlebens hätte mit einem etwas schwächer dimensionierten Anschluss.
Ich habe aber auch ein Deutschland-Ticket, obwohl ich nicht jeden Tag oder nicht
jeden Monat damit die günstigste Option habe.
Ja, also manchmal fahre ich sicherlich nicht genug öffentlichen Personennahverkehr,
dass dieses Ticket für mich einen Vorteil, einen finanziellen,
unmittelbaren, spürbaren Vorteil gibt. Wahrscheinlich zahle ich in einigen Monaten drauf.
Trotzdem möchte ich meinen Beitrag dazu leisten, dass dieses Modell...
Existiert und erhalten bleibt. Weil ich daran glaube, dass es sinnvoll ist,
wenn möglichst große Teile der Gesellschaft einfach eine ÖPNV-Flat haben und
sich damit viel bewegen.
Gut, jetzt kann ich diese beiden Dinge auch bezahlen.
Und dann gibt es eben, also ist ja auch erkennbar, Menschen,
die sagen, pass auf, dieses Geld verschwende ich nicht, ich decke meinen Bedarf.
Aber dann, an dem Punkt würde ich jetzt denken, ist die Konsequenz,
dann muss der Staat das eben subventionieren.
Da muss der Staat hingehen oder wir sagen, pass auf Leute, from the people that
brought you Verbrenner aus, hier ist die nächste Idee, die wir haben, Kupfer aus. Ha!
So, und also, dass man da irgendwie diese,
Transformation in eine moderne Welt aktiv vorantreibt, halte ich für notwendig,
insbesondere bei Infrastrukturbau.
Naja, dann kann man halt eigentlich nur wieder die Idee der Datenautobahn reinbringen.
Also wenn die einzelnen privaten Unternehmen das nicht hinkriegen,
dann muss halt der Staat dafür sorgen, dass die ganzen Glasfaserstrecken zentral
bereitgestellt werden,
zum Beispiel von der Bundesnetzagentur und die Heimanbieter sich letzten Endes
nur auf diesen Glasfaserstrecken einmieten.
Und das ist ein höherer Investitionsaufwand sicherlich beim Staat,
aber der stellt dann halt einfach sicher, dass es da ist.
Man wartet ja auch nicht darauf, dass dann irgendwie irgendein Privatunternehmen
anfängt, hier mal eine Autobahn zu bauen,
sondern das ist sozusagen Teil einer zentralen Versorgungsplanung und einer
Unterstützung einer wirtschaftlichen Aktivität und die muss natürlich genauso
auch auf digitaler Ebene stattfinden.
Und ich denke, das ist irgendwie in den Köpfen noch nicht angekommen.
Das ist halt alles so kompliziert, das macht man dann eben mit den Unternehmen.
Und das ist ja auch, mal angenommen, du hättest jetzt irgendein Dorf,
wo es keine Nachfrage nach Glasfaser gibt, weil da irgendwie gerade die Population
dort jedes Jahr ein Jahr älter wird und das schon sehr lange.
Dann würdest du ja diesen Standort durch das Schaffen von Glas für andere Menschen
attraktiv machen, das heißt nachfragegetrieben würdest du nicht auf die Idee kommen das zu machen,
wenn es einmal da ist dann wächst da auf einmal aber auch eine schöne Pflanze
und deswegen glaube ich ist ein,
nachfragegetriebener Ausbau von Infrastruktur wahrscheinlich nicht der optimale
der müsste wie gesagt forciert werden Ich würde also sagen, Kupferverbot,
Verbrennerverbot, Kupferverbot, Glaszwang, Subventionen, was könnte man noch machen?
Irgendwie, um das zu forcieren.
Einfach verstaatlichen alles.
Kommunismus jetzt.
Kommunismus jetzt. Ja, da gibt es,
vom zentralen Datenzentrum gibt es dann Daten. Ja, ich wollte das auf jeden Fall mal,
besprechen, dass ich das eben dann doch faszinierend schade finde.
Und die Gründe will ich nicht invalidieren und natürlich kann ich das alles
verstehen, aber dann müssen wir eben staatlich anders steuern.
Wenn das die Gründe sind, warum wir dieses Land nicht mit einer zukunftsfähigen
Infrastruktur versorgen, wenn wir immer nur gesagt hätten, was wir gerade brauchen,
dann wären wir, glaube ich, nicht so weit gekommen.
Ja, ich erinnere daran. Also Glasfaser-Initiative hatten wir so Ende der 70er
Jahre schon und ist dann aber leider abgesagt worden von Herrn Kohl.
Stattdessen haben wir dann Kabelfernsehen bekommen.
Ja, also besser als nix.
Mehr brauche ich nicht. Ich brauche nur Kabelfernsehen.
So, lass noch ein paar Termine raushauen und dann verabschieden wir uns Ja.
Wir verabschieden uns Zwei klitzekleine Termine Der 39C3, den haben wir schon
angekündigt Da ist jetzt glaube ich auch nochmal der zweite Vorverkaufstermin Wann ist der?
Montag der 17.
Am Montag um wie viel Uhr?
Ich glaube um 20 Uhr.
Jetzt nichts Falsches. Ja,
20 Uhr hast du absolut recht. Also Montag, der 17. November um 20 Uhr geht das klicken.
Und natürlich wurden jetzt von denjenigen, die beim ersten Pre-Sale leer ausgegangen
sind, schon sehr viele sehr nervös.
Ich betrachte das ein bisschen entspannter, weil am Anfang sehr,
sehr viele Leute da klicken und jede, die da in den Shop kommt,
kauft vielleicht auch noch mal mit einer etwas größeren Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Ticket zu viel.
Das heißt, da kann man sich eigentlich schon immer darauf verlassen,
dass es da noch einen Zweitmarkt gibt und wünsche dann allen viel Erfolg und
Glück und auch diejenigen, die bei dem zweiten Verkauf kein Glück haben,
den würde ich einfach empfehlen,
auf den Hashtags der sogenannten sozialen Medien ein bisschen die Augen aufzuhalten,
weil da dann doch schon noch sehr viel sich auch im Nachhinein ermöglicht.
Und ich bin am, jetzt heißt das, das ist gar nicht genau, 11., nee, 10.
Dezember, am 10. Dezember halte ich die Keynote bei der Black Hat Europe in London.
Worum geht's?
Ich muss den Titel nochmal kurz raussuchen Ich glaube Cyber Check all boxes
before you get pawned ist mein Titel, den Vortrag habe ich noch nicht konzipiert,
aber ich habe schon meinen Titel,
Falls jemand Falls wir Hörende in London haben Könnten wir uns da,
Alright Supi.
Dann machen wir Schluss und wir hören uns demnächst wieder und sagen erstmal Tschüss und bis bald.
Bis dahin, ciao, ciao.